es momento de hablar de economía este 6
de noviembre bienvenidos a esta sección
con nuestra especialista económica
daniel hablando con ramírez daniela muy
buenas noches cuba flexibilizará el
monopolio estatal sobre la venta de
alimentos harán muy buenas noches mire
hoy en día los agricultores y
procesadores de alimentos no pueden
venderle directamente a un particular
sino que el estado es intermediario como
parte de las medidas para hacer frente a
la crisis económica el gobierno les va a
permitir vender sus productos en el
mercado mayorista y minorista siempre y
cuando cumplan primero con determinado
suministro para las empresas estatales
los medios locales informan que el
gobierno también flexibilizaría algunos
controles de precios que tiene hoy en
día recordemos que este país importa el
60 por ciento de los alimentos que
consume y con la pandemia se ha
dificultado aún más el acceso
estas medidas traen a la memoria unas
similares que se adoptaron hace una
década pero en 2016 fueron revertidas
sin mayores explicaciones
daniela siguió bajando el desempleo en
eeuu
la tasa de desocupación se desaceleró
por sexto mes consecutivo al 69 en
octubre desde el 79 por ciento que había
finalizado en septiembre cuando empezó
la pandemia el desempleo se disparó de
inmediato y en abril llegó al 14 7% la
peor cifra desde la gran depresión es a
pesar de que en febrero venía en su
nivel más bajo en medio siglo en octubre
se agregaron 683 mil puestos de trabajo
mucho menos que en los meses anteriores
de hecho apenas se han recuperado 12
millones de los 22 millones de plazas
laborales que se perdieron durante la
crisis la preocupación de este informe
laboral es que alrededor de 12 millones
de personas llevan más de seis meses sin
trabajo
vamos a europa y es que el gobierno de
francia emprendió una campaña para
promover al país como un destino de
inversión si el presidente de francia
emmanuel macrón se reunió este viernes
de manera virtual con los presidentes de
8 grupos empresariales entre ellos
algunos tan conocidos como unilever o
coca-cola o trata de la india y su arma
de conquista son los impuestos y
decidimos en francia un paquete de
recuperación muy ambicioso llamado
reinicio de francia más de 100 mil
millones de euros con perspectivas
precisamente basadas en otras reformas
hechas antes para acelerar las
inversiones especialmente en lo verde y
lo digital
esos 100 mil millones de los que habla
de manuel macrón son una partida para
reducir impuestos e invertir en
proyectos de energía renovable en los
próximos dos años
daniela otra empresa que anuncia que se
va de argentina se trata de walmart la
cadena de venta minorista estadounidense
más grande del mundo que vendió toda su
operación en el país
local a una cadena local aunque de
origen colombiano pero que se llama el
grupo de narváez que también tiene
operaciones en ecuador y en uruguay o en
marte se instaló en el país en 1995 con
un local en avellaneda hoy 25 años
después es el noveno empleador privado
más grande de argentina tiene 9.000
trabajadores en 92 tiendas distribuidas
en 21 provincias y en buenos aires pero
esta no es la primera empresa que hace
parte de este éxodo para la vela lo hizo
hace poco así como la aerolínea latam o
la plataforma über its entre muchas
otras a las bonos con los indicadores
económicos de este viernes oeste del
cerro en terreno mixto este viernes pero
despidió la semana electoral con sus
mayores ganancias desde abril en europa
los parques rompieron su racha de
subidas con excepción de londres y en
asia la bolsa de tokio cerró en su nivel
más alto desde 1991 ante una posible
victoria de joe biden
en américa latina sao paulo subió por
cuarto día consecutivo y chile tuvo un
avance significativo
y cerramos con tu cifra del día son los
250 dólares que cuesta la botella que es
la tequila el millonario y lo demás que
acaba de lanzar esta bebida alcohólica
con el nombre de su marca de autos de
lujo todo inició como una broma en
twitter hace un par de años era un día
de inocentes un 28 de diciembre y él
lanzó un tuit en el que anunciaba su
proyecto y todos se rieron en ese
momento pero en este momento ya es
realidad pero si está pensando en
comprarla alan pues le tengo una mala
noticia y es que se agotó en cuestión de
horas y solamente estaba disponible para
eeuu el saludo daniela muchas gracias
por el recorrido económico y ustedes por
su compañía vea más mucho más en france
i